[Music]
now does anybody in this room know how
to twerk it's all in and then you just
move your thumb up and down like that
and that's twerking
[Music]
no no way
okay
oh wow sir listen okay and that that
that clip right there just [__] up my
whole argument
that that clip right there [__] up my
whole argument no no you're gonna have
to give me a minute you're gonna have to
give me a minute you're gonna have to
give me a minute because I was like I
don't really care if people dress up and
[__] and people are in Dragon are just
reading stories and stuff like that you
know what I mean I don't care about that
that that that that that that that's not
what I I care for
um because it's not necessarily
inherently sexual then you talk about
twerking and for the kids and I'm like
[__] [__] okay but yeah please what's
your problem with what's your problem
that's that's that's not where it's
supposed to be but what is your problem
with uh people it's just like nah be
there's ages for that
there's certain things that you don't
want your kids to be exposed at a
certain age
and the twerking part it's not no what
are you what is you doing
I'm gonna say something that might
surprise people
I don't give a [__] that they're drag
queens no I don't want no grown adult
teaching kids about [__] twerking
schools forget that there was a drag
queen running up on Karate I don't even
care I wouldn't want a man or a woman on
all fours
what is happening and people are
clapping adults are sitting there in
cognitive dissonance sexualizing a child
in a way that's so abnormal no this used
to be racy stuff for adults in music
videos to do way back in the day and
even back then it was y'all doing this
to kids nah B that's not it that's not
it this is a sickness of the highest
order
[Music]
who wants to be a drag queen when they
grow up
[Applause]
Drake should be an all-ages thing and
some people consider it provocative is
not inappropriate
I just looked at a nine-year-old
what the [__] am I anyone can do drag
everyone can do drag well it's just so
[__] weird this shit's so goddamn
weird let's keep it a stack I'm gonna
say this drag queens are not for kids
drag shows are not for kids
the whole history and the concept that
its roots are not for children and you
all trying to sell this [__] as if it is
is a [__] lie it is a weird one
you know what shall we possibly second
yeah I went to my daughter's school
yesterday and I had to have to pick her
up you know she's nine I have to pick
her up from her pole dance class
yeah it's a good Fitness
um program you know it helps with the
strength and stuff like that
if you're taking pole dance
and you're removing the x-working fact
of the pole dance
you're gentrifying it it's length Okay
let's not act like no no it's not it's
not it's yeah it's not that it's
something else it's that what in the
hell has a drag queen ever done to make
you have so much respect for them and
admire them so much
other than put on makeup and and jump on
the floor and ride around and do sexual
things on stage I have absolutely no
idea why you would want that to
influence your child would you want a
stripper or a star to influence your
child
it makes no sense at all
a drag queen performs in a nightclub for
adults there is a lot of Filth that goes
on a lot of sexual stuff that goes on we
have already had a reputation of being
files and being perverts and deviants we
don't need you to bring your children
around so you keep your kids at home or
take them to Disneyland or take them to
Chuck E cheese hold up hold up I can you
can extend it to a lot of different
lines of work yeah better quote unquote
legal but I still wouldn't want them
y'all gonna do shows for escorts too
like what is what is it about a drag
queen that you feel are fit to be
Educators one and two even if it's just
dumb education stuff that they do and
that anybody can really teach why do we
need drag queens to do it
is this some kind of initiative to do
for what though I don't even understand
what the point of this kind of thing is
to make kids realize that drag queen why
do kids need to realize that teams that
[__] when they older we're not doing
that for strippers we're not doing that
for a lot of other lines of work that
are for adults only
like it's a very bizarre thing that I'm
watching unfold in front of me right
we're watching grown ass men
cosplayers women with these like
ridiculous makeup and outfits doing
outfits that are hyper sexualized okay
and we're sending them off what a
confusing [__] thing to witness as a
grown man I watch this and I'm like
that's weird
y'all doing that for kids
and trying to convince him is cool
but why
can anyone tell me
curious in what ways is educational at
any point why do I need a drag queen to
come teach this stuff and guess what
some of the content they're teaching is
a little bit such too but we won't even
go to that why do we need this why is
this good for the curriculum vast
majority of U.S adults
including parents say they don't want
their kids involved in any of these
kinds of drag shows so why is the
education system pushing this [__] so
hard I'm really curious
what's the sensualization that they want
to create I don't know it's like going
to a field trip in a brewery when you're
five
why would I go in a brewery nothing bad
is gonna happen there technically
technically it's it's it's I mean
they're not gonna drink but they're
gonna go to a brewery to see how we make
beer why don't they do
it's not its place it's not the time
it's not the place well what do you mean
like they're they're kids they're under
18 and everything is tough they it's
chemistry
yeah I understand what you're saying but
no there's a reason why we don't do it
that's it I want to go on a field trip
on a brew in the brewery and I'm not
even one of these conservative folks who
feel like all these LGBT yourself is
crazy I don't even care because I
haven't been there
I don't want straight people doing this
I don't want whatever else dude I don't
care whatever I don't care why are y'all
doing this with kids
and when you defend this stuff you're
like no this is fantastic this is great
you look very suspicious
to parents
that was the thing that happened uh uh
on the Ellen DeGeneres Show
you Nicki Minaj
with that kid I was like and they were
clapping
yeah okay that kid's role model is Nicki
Minaj and I understand like the the
whatever you call the Nicki Minaj fans
are gonna probably come up to us and
that kid was like yeah Nikki and then
baby baby baby and start [__] or mental
flight she has other songs
when that kids go on YouTube and then
after you go yeah and I know it's not
Nikki's fault like yeah the parachute
whatever what not Nick Nikki's not a
role model for kids
it's not a role model that I want for
kids it's a role model for other people
for other things and I get that for kids
that age nah I'm sorry I'm not having it
no she got other songs
yes an anaconda is not a snake
but you got kids singing that [__] super
so so it's like and then I know and I
don't even think it's just that even the
violent stuff I don't think is great all
right well if I can have my son my kids
trying to listen to drill all day are
you crazy yeah okay going to come to me
like yeah another Wick is my yeah
bro listen
I just want people to rethink some of
this stuff forget the political aspect
of it I don't care what do you think is
right for children do you think these
kids should be visited by escorts by do
you guys think that and for what reason
would you think that's a good idea so
then try to tell me why this would be
good that's all I want to know if you
can tell me great and God bless them but
that's not that's not it
nor do we talking about I take my drink
or might be gay why because he's blowing
[__] that's a crazy